okay thank you very much for having me
here talking about this work that we've
been doing in the past 23 years and my
name is Mark Antonio t I come from Milan
I've been here in Berkeley many years
ago but that's what I'm doing now I'm
going to talk about these set of
algorithms that we have developed that
attack the problem of inferring up
regression model for cancer and the
motivation that spurred us to work on
this problem was a collaboration that we
started with some researchers on a colon
cancer in Milan at the Institute
incinerate amore and eventually we found
all the world by Augustin where there is
a initial probably the first progression
model was described in the paper now as
we went on we all course bumped into
other problems and there are the
problems of what happens when you have
cancer the balls and subdivide sin
becomes more heterogeneous and where you
have a different clonal populations that
keeping that occupied the whole volume
of the cancer and this is a nice light
that I put up because this is an
original drawing by Darwin so just to
make the whole thing interesting now the
problem that we started looking at was a
suppose we want to describe what a
process of accumulation of different
mutations different alterations looks
like what kind of data we have around
and it turns out that most of the data
that is around is cross-sectional data
and cross-sectional data this is an
example this is the mail
ski paper on lung cancer and it always
looks like these you have basically
different genes that have a certain
alteration associated to it and the
columns are patients okay so this is the
kind of data that you get and this is
the kind of data that you have for
example in TCGA so there is very little
timing information associated to this
kind of data and our problem is to
reconstruct to superimpose a temporal
structure on this sort of on on this
data to extract a temporal structure
from this data so turns out that there
are two ways of looking at this problem
one way is what we call the ensemble
cross-sectional data which is what can
be done on data sets coming for example
from TCGA okay these are data that have
our list of mutations a list of
alterations associated to each patient
and then you can do also what is called
the individual level analysis and this
is coming becoming more interesting and
more important because of for example of
single-cell data [ __ ] of data that is
coming from sections of the single tumor
so they but on the bulk of our work has
been on a cross-sectional data okay so
the data is called like that time of
biopsies and that's basically at the
kind of the timestamp the only times
time that you did you have okay so let's
keep going and here you have a summary
of the two different look at the two
different aspects that of the same
problem and I are reporting this picture
here because the algorithms that we
developed can be applied in both
settings although on the individual
level settings we have
very little results to show we just
looked at the Gallagher's data set which
was mentioned in one of the previous
talks but for the time being it's a we
are writing up and we are trying to get
more interesting more results out of it
so I'm the main work that we've done is
on assemble reconstruction and the some
other construction that we came up with
is based on a particular is basically a
Bayesian network learning scheme but
it's based on a particular kind of score
and the score that we are using is a
first of all let me just tell you that
there are several days many of them have
been originally developed here in
Berkeley Furman and of course they're
some of the people sitting in the
audience have been doing a lot of work
on this okay all algorithms meet some
measure to decide whether and how to
include an arkham and our choice is
rooted in probabilistic causality theory
we are using a score which is the ride
from the theory of probabilistic
causality that was developed by suppes
in Stanford over the years he passed
away about a year ago if I remember
correctly so it's a very simple idea up
to a point and we reinterpret these
scoring and the relations the relation
that it generates between different
alterations as a relation of selective
advantage between two alterations
basically we say that we can score the
relation and we can say that one
alteration confers the two more a
selective advantage in order to
acquire subsequently the next alteration
this is a an interesting interpretation
which was suggested by one of the
reviewers or one of the of one of the
papers that we published on the subject
and it it's also interesting because it
he kind of let me just be very candid
here he makes the whole notion of
causality much more palatable to button
to biologists biologist maybe in any
case so but the bottom line is that the
choice of this particular scoring method
allows us to pack more information in
the reconstruction algorithm okay and
the algorithm a temporal are temporal
without timing let's be clear okay we
haven't done work on timing yet it's in
the pipeline so but the result is that
you can say that there is some deep
relation between two events in one of
the models that we do we come up with so
this is a typical example that we show
there is an assumption in our model is
that old alterations are persistent
which opens up a kind of warmth
regarding other kind of alterations that
you may want to look at you have in this
case for example EGFR mutation gets to
this cell this cell keeps dividing but
because it has a GF r as a mutation
acquire then it has higher chance of
getting a mutation of cdk and therefore
you get a later on a clonal expansion of
cells that have both mutations okay so
this is a simple example these are the
kind of probabilities that we need to
compute and the two
the probabilities that we are computing
are of two kinds well actually there is
one specific kind which is the condition
that details what it means for one event
to be the cost for another it's a very
simple conditional probability and what
is happening here is that you are just
looking at your just observing the
frequencies and based on the frequencies
you are computing this probability there
is an extra little complication here in
the sense that our setup is capable of
dealing with potentially arbitrarily
complex boolean formula or combination
of different alterations that have been
acquired by a certain population of
cells okay this is a typical example
we've seen it somewhere in another talk
before as well is the problem of
deciding whether you have what happens
when you have an overlap you have
patient a has these alterations here
they should be sorry you see this
alteration here using this alteration be
in these other samples and you have an
overlap so the question is what kind of
networking you infer given these
measurements and this is wrong because
it would look like that from see you
would infer a and leave be by itself but
if you want to look at hard exclusivity
or even soft exclusivity so standard or
or sore then these are the kind of
networks that you want to infer and our
our algorithms are capable of dealing
with the exactly with this problem here
okay so let me just give you a little
bit of advertisement this is the library
okay these are the three papers that we
have published on the algorithms that
are present in the library right here
these are the performance comparisons of
our algorithms Capri and caprese the
difference is that caprese works or
construct tree topologies while Capri
oops while Capri reconstruct more much
more complex dag topologies okay and we
have we have different kind of setups
these are data from this is DC simulated
data and these are some of the other
some of the other tools that we have
compared it against and what you can see
here is a that of course well one thing
that you can see here if you go a little
bit more into details is that our
algorithms are also very robust with
respect to noise so the last thing that
we've been doing recently x2 fds a setup
and sample level individual level but
above all we have put together a
pipeline for applying these tools and
these tools are capri especially is
actually used at the very bottom at a
very downstream of a pipeline of
analysis and we where we decided we did
a quite a bit of work actually you will
see later on who actually did the work
not me in any case we had to do a lot of
work in order to analyze a specific data
set we have several data said that we
are analyzing now but the main that I
said we analyzed is the TCGA econo
cancer data set and the key point was
that we found that in order to produce
meaningful reconstructed progression
models you have to be very careful about
what is the input data and especially
you want to be very sure that what
you're putting into the system is a
corresponds to a very
well defined cancer subtype and so a big
chunk of the pipeline up to this point
is to find a cancer subtypes driver
events and cancer subtypes then then
going here we are also using exclusivity
finding tools in order to automatically
produce some of the patterns some of the
formulae that we are then input into
into capron so this is one example of
the result that you get out of Capri
this is a TCG a code reader okay the
interesting thing is that okay this is
worth it's done in collaboration with
the econ collegia hospital in a research
center in barcelona so this has been a
validated ex post by an oncologist and
the interesting thing is that we were
able to find are all four well we were
able to propose we haven't validated yet
in the one on experimentally but we were
able to propose a role for sox9 in as a
downstream event of mutation acquired on
added one added my so this is an
interesting little result looking out of
these analyses so the tronco is on trunk
is the name of the algorithm suit is
owned by a conductor you can download it
play with it and here the main
characters you Luca Ravana was the
postdoc and anila ramazzotti is
finishing in three weeks and then is
coming here to Stanford and Alex grabbed
ANC the other postdoc from Siena and
these are all the other people involved
there's a his master student there's bud
mishra from New York University who
actually came up with the idea of using
that
particular score ok Rebecca sans
Pamplona in Victor moreno in Barcelona
work with our setup so final
acknowledgement you have a new journal
embody especially give some money for
hoodies ok and some other ties meant I'm
organizing a yearly school on in common
this year is May 24 27 ok and you can
check it out and obviously you can come
and if you don't trust me talk to Niko
was there I'm done
Thank You second oh but I do understand
the connection to the selective
advantage because there seems to be no
notion of of growth rate it's really not
we really do not have any particular
interpretation in that sense it's a
selective advantage for us simply means
that if you are looking at the data in
you are really seeing a lot of
alterations okay in one gene then you
can mathematically say that this
population is a heza as a higher chance
of acquiring a mutation later on and so
in some sense your comment is that the
way I interpreted is that maybe we are
putting too much we are going too much
on the other in the other direction but
seriously it is a when adding the first
paper we that we brought we everything
was described in terms of causality
theorem and that really draw a lot of
fire and that this was the suggestion
about so the term causality is really
something and it makes sense because you
can go and talk about you can go and
look at the edible Wars from Judea pearl
where you have this notion of
intervention and so how do you define an
intervention by an artery by a mutation
okay so it's really you know we decided
to tread very lightly and adopt a more
neutral terminology which would be a
more understandable my
biologist yes just to be I don't think
selector that it has a neutral
connotation it's what it's selective
advantage specific connotation and so I
think maybe you've gone from one
controversial do and either okay are you
gonna America I'll accept I'll accept
the criticism yes okay and i love it
I'll keep it in mind yet okay maybe
that's question in the example of a so
how do you know a and B a a it's aches
or B or a or b now what I'm saying okay
that's yes you could have the data may
support also the opposite okay but the
way the data may support the opposite
but what we are doing we are imposing
some constraint on the way the our
Empower causal implications are built so
the system will only find these sort of
the sort of of relationships this is
because first of all we are kind of
cheating because we are inputting these
nodes as atomic notes in the seed
network that then is used to do the
structure of the construction of the
bedroom model because as soon as you
have a formula of this kind and
especially as soon as you have these
junctions your complexity blows up very
very quickly okay so we are in a sense
we are we are cheating but it's it's not
really being that dishonest about in the
sense that these are especially the
exclusivity relationships we either have
them suggested that directly directly by
physiol by a clinician or biologist and
this is the case in another study that
we did on a CML now our colleague from
the hospital in Milan that suggested to
specific exclusivity patterns or in the
pipeline that I showed in the very end
here
in this pipeline pipeline the
exclusivity groups are suggested by
software like like mutex so we are just
taking this formula and we are just
menteng the input we are just
technically the term is we are lifting
the input matrix in order to get these
new nodes in the uniform in the input ok
that's a discreet ASIC we have a lot to
discuss both tomorrow and on Thursday
what's going to revolution yes a mutual
exclusivity so they stank the speakers
again